so we told you about the fact that this
is under 2 big headings when we think
about straight-line motion we want to
think about does the directory matter or
does it not this is not necessary but
just to fill in some knowledge for all
of you and particularly to connect it
with the physics people are like oh yes
this is a thing I know about good
morning well we talked about Direction
mattering what we're talking about is
quantities that are what we call vectors
oh something's wrong in my pencil this
morning vectors right vectors are things
which have a magnitude a size and they
also have a direction like positive or
negative or you can actually have
directions that go in all which way
whatever but for us because we're only
in a straight line you can only go one
way or its opposite because that's all
you've got on the line okay when you
don't worry about the direction when all
you're caring about is the magnitude the
size right we call that a scalar so
everything you can see on the left-hand
column are what we call vector
quantities they're vectors where is
everything on the right-hand column are
scalars your earlier size or something
whatever
okay now the hey this morning is about
motion with calculus so we talked about
the change in these different aspects
whether you carry out direction or not
but we only thought about it in average
terms that's all you can do without
calculus right but now that we do have
calculus we can do better than just
working out the change over a period of
time calculus allows us to work out
gradient not over an interval but
gradient at a point right now what that
corresponds to in motion terms is we can
say not just change over time but change
at an instant of time because it's
change at a single instant in time but
at a single point
this is also called instantaneous change
does this ring a bell what was our last
topic it was or subtopic I should say it
was exponential growth of decay and we
had a table just like this where we
considered average growth rates and we
also considered instantaneous growth
rates do you remember that so how do we
work out the change at an instant well
if we call that lets switch color if we
call that V for velocity okay this is
now getting to the point where we really
emphasize down here and this is actually
a question you will see less and less as
you go further through the course okay
all we're comparing is on the left hand
column displacement how it changes in
comparison to time we want the
derivative that relates those two okay
so if I'm comparing displacement I would
say D X and when I compare that with how
time is changing I would say on D T
right now differentiating with respect
to time is pretty much as common as
differentiating with respect to X you
know how when you started everything was
did wild DX do RDX and we hardly ever
saw anything else never we moved into
rates of change and we're like oh you
might differentiate with respect to the
radius or with respect to the length of
the side of a triangle or something like
that
time is the one that you're going to see
most frequently from this point on okay
it's not the only one but as a
consequence of it being so common we get
a new little piece of notation that
means specifically differentiate with
respect to time and it's X with a little
dot over the top okay so you've seen X -
I'm not a huge fan of X - because of how
similar it looks to x ^ 1 because of how
lazy I am when I write ones but X dot
pretty much universally means this and
you might confuse it with anything else
also you will see X dot a whole lot so
you want to recognize it okay now this
is going to be a value and it's going to
have positive or negative which
indicates its direction but if we want
to think about where direction doesn't
matter all you have to do is take this
derivative take its value and say well
don't worry about whether it's positive
or negative that's it that's all you
have to worry about ok take the absolute
value and you're there now we go from
there quantity displacement distance
whatever down to this change at an
instant by way of a first derivative
right we differentiate once and this is
what we get what would happen if we
differentiated another time well if you
think about how velocity is
changing over time we have a name for
that concept we call it acceleration so
you can put that over here in the left
hand side acceleration now just like
velocity above acceleration a gets lots
of different ways to describe her and
we're gonna cover a few here so firstly
by definition money by definition
acceleration is the change in velocity
over time so that's the change in
velocity right that's D V I'll make it a
bit bigger for you right over time okay
but since V itself is also a derivative
see up there right V is a derivative
so if you differentiate that a game I
can say that actually acceleration is
not just the derivative velocity it's
also the second derivative of
displacement okay now because it's the
second derivative of displacement you
differentiate X with respect to time
twice I cannot just call it that but you
know because that's a bit of a long
thing to write I can say well it's an X
dot which is differentiate with respect
to time once it's X double dot which
looks kind of like a weird emoji but
it's it's the acceleration okay so
you're like wow all these different ways
to say acceleration and they all be the
same thing now I I'm n shinned before
that we're going to complete this table
except for a teeny little bit this is
all we're going to cover for now at the
table is it's complete okay this is
everything that is two units students
you'll need to cover in motion but this
last little box down here acceleration
we are going to return to it in an
extension one way a little bit later on
so like I said make sure you don't lose
this page why now one more thing before
we actually get started doing some
questions okay I'm gonna scroll down a
little bit yeah here we go here's one I
prepared earlier up okay now I just want
to make a quick note about acceleration
because it's such a weird and important
word okay acceleration has two
completely separate meanings depending
on who says the word and in what
texts so if you were just having a
conversation with someone on the street
and you're saying my car is accelerating
right all they mean is you're speeding
up right put your foot on the
accelerator right and it makes your car
go faster okay now I want you to hear
the words that I'm using and note that
when we're talking about speed we're
only talking about the the magnitude of
how fast you go we don't care about
direction right which is why the
opposite of accelerating in that
colloquial sense is decelerating which
means you're not increasing your speed
you're decreasing in speed right that's
the way we would talk about things in in
normal terms okay that is not how we
talk about things in mathematics and
physics okay and this is something
hurray we actually share in common with
them well we talk about acceleration in
this sense and in the course this is the
only sense I'm going to talk about into
acceleration so in this room this is
what acceleration means it just means
that the velocity is changing now that
can mean it's getting bigger or it's
getting smaller getting more negative or
less negative just change in any way at
all
okay and what that means is if you're
accelerating in a positive or negative
direction that's something you could
talk about because it's a vector
it's got Direction built into it right
as a consequence you can go ahead and
write this right put like a big red
warning for yourself to never ever say
the word decelerating in this course
okay it has a colloquial meaning but it
is so confusing with what we're talking
about down here and we never really talk
about this is why I left this part here
right I left it open we never really
talked about acceleration with regard to
like what we don't care about distance
we don't really talk about it as a
scalar in the context of this course so
as a consequence just don't use the word
decelerate it's just not worth it
if you're wondering why would I even use
the word decelerating sometimes they
will ask you to describe in words
describe verbally the motion of an
object particle a car a ball weight a
person they will say use some words
here's an equation tell me what is going
on and you'll be tempted to work use the
word decelerating when at some point you
see it slowing down but that's such a
confusing way to describe it based on
what we talked about as acceleration
that I'm going to encourage you to never
ever use that word okay